so one of the astonishing facts from the
human genome project was that single
nucleotide variants occur approximately
one every 300 nucleotides so if you do
the math that means there are roughly 10
million single nucleotide variants in
the human genome and these variations
are one contributing factor to the
genetic diversity in humans
and so this opened up a whole new set of
questions so what is the intersection
between disease and genetic variants
what's the relationship between drug
metabolism and genetic variation
is there a cancer genome and does that
cancer genome change over time and in in
between the the primary tumor and a
metastasis or a recurrence
how does the genome impact mental health
behavioral health
it had already been observed that some
diseases were more prevalent in certain
populations and so then questions about
what's the role of genetic variation in
ethnicity
and so over the years that followed the
completion of the human genome reference
sequence it became more and more clear
that we knew too little
we realized that there was a need for a
more concerted effort to understand
genomic variation so the nih announced
its support of precision medicine in
2015 when then president obama and his
state of the union address described
precision medicine as an emerging
approach to disease prevention and
treatment that takes into account
people's individual variations in genes
environment and lifestyle
so this was accompanied by a publication
in the new england journal of medicine
written by then director of the nih
francis collins and past director of the
national cancer institute harold varmus
this perspective further supported the
convictions of president obama that
science offers great potential for
improving human health and this
officially launched the nih precision
medicine initiative in 2015. one of the
common visions for all type of labs is
that they will make use of the
automation and digitalization so the
digital infrastructure needs to take
into account the large volume and
variety of data that is being produced
some later on challenges can be avoided
if the organizations have data
centricity in mind when implementing the
new systems and workflows and
automations
and one of the general
challenges that all labs are facing
is how to capture this large amount of
data that is being produced
including the contextual data
in a fair format which means to be
findable to be accessible to be
interoperable and reusable
and how to redesign the current
paper-based workflow what is the future
for our species you know in in
korea's previous talk he was talking
about the factors that are involved in
space exploration and how we can study
the expression of genes and things like
that in space exploration but we've only
really just begun human space
exploration we don't really know what
happens to our species with another
century or a millennium of space
exploration where our species goes a big
question is will we see this idea of the
singularity of all of us kind of merging
into our machines when our technology
advances so fast that we basically
become the machine or the machine takes
over and leaves us behind
we don't know what that looks like it
might be likely that a lot of life out
there in the universe is post biological
life that most life is artificial
intelligence um and basically written in
silicon and other materials of metal
rather than being built in organic
chemistry as we are
it's really important in your life in
your career no matter which field you
pursue is that you find the right
mentors
and i've seen this a lot i think because
of how we structured academia a lot of
young people a lot of early career
researchers they think a mentor is just
a teacher
or an advisor like an academic advisor
and that's really not the case a good
mentor is far more than that a good
mentor is someone who knows when to be
your friend and when to be your boss
it's someone who knows how to teach you
but how to help you to learn how to
teach yourself
a good mentor is someone in your life
who is really going to be there for you
to help you answer questions
to steer you in the right direction when
you feel like you don't know which way
to go but also to to allow you to grow
in your own ways and so a mentor is
someone whose hindsight can become your
foresight for those of us out here in
the world who've been very fortunate and
blessed and honored to be mentors for
young students and what is my
informatics in the time of high
throughput biology
now modern medicine and biology has gone
a tremendous improvement in evolution i
would say it's a revolution
in current
age where we have so much of high
throughput you know technologies where
we can measure
different modalities uh from you know we
can do imaging we can understand tissue
composition we can do genotyping we can
actually also leverage the powerful
omics like genomics transcriptomics
proteomics
not only from organs but our tissues our
cells but also in vitro settings or in
vivo settings all these taken together
when we sequence them we can actually
build up a map or network
at a cellular level right and these when
put into sequencing machines can
actually build a huge information
complex of multi-omics
in information that can help us to tease
out the different molecular uh features
which can help which when integrated
properly can help us to understand the
disease progression we at tauber
bioinformatics research center are a
team of biologists bioinformaticians
mathematicians and computer scientists
and and we uh developed this t bioinfo
platform where we implement open source
and sometimes our own
algorithms today we want to share with
you some of these
new sections that we have been working
on our
manifold utilities section
then we will move to the single cell rna
jump right to spatial single cell
analysis and then we will kind of uh
move gears and we will uh speak about
metagenomics
analysis
and finally talk about uh the importance
of uh containers
in bioinformatics i'd like to show you
how we're
buying for the platform start page
firstly we need to go
to data integration and manifold
and modern
zone
when we choose the manifold utilities
section
here we can select the
type of data dataset it can be object
features table
or distance matrix for graph
which will be
used as precomputed graph for
manifold method
let's get
object features table
for mice expression dataset
and upload it to the platform
let's check a visualization
great your map approach works
we can see dividing of samples into two
clusters uh control samples and
threesome samples well it was a great
breakthrough when
a single cell was developed compared to
bug dna it allowed us to
specifically study separate cells
but when we
analyze data using single cell we end up
with something like this
cells in an artificial dimensions in
this case it's umap but we never really
know where exactly in our tissue the
cells are located
um and with spatial transcriptomics
finally we have this opportunity to map
the cells to our tissue but other than
organs we also can look at for example
biofilm populations
um this is the clustering of different
functions that cells individual cells
it's used a lot in medicine also it's
very useful to identify the invasive
margin of the tumor and actually how the
cells this cancer interact
microtracking two was an interesting
study and actually that was the first
human related space biology study
that was sponsored by the space biology
program and so the study was looking at
as i mentioned taking samples from the
environment so we were swagging
different surfaces
dining table
toilet exercise equipment and so forth
and then we were also taking samples
from the crew so we were taking samples
from their mouth from the nose and from
different skin
areas so like forearms and the navels
and behind the ears and so forth so
obviously
these days
so after collecting samples from
the station or the and then those are
returned to the ground and then
obviously we use half throughput methods
to be able to characterize the
microbiome environment and so here's the
snapshots
looking at the relative abundance so the
top 12
genera time is a tool that analyzes meta
genomics data this culture independent
microbial communities and what we
basically learn about them is
composition and function of
these communities
and it can be applied in a bunch of
areas like agriculture healthcare where
we can study microbiomes of different
organs
or ecology where biosensors are
developed using
metagenomics and by degradation of
plastic is also bacteria during process
and of course biotechnology so on the
platform we present three modules
pre-processing that
consists of filtering and denoising
algorithms then we go on to taxonomy
with silver classification filtering our
classified sequences and conducting
phytogenetic trees
then we can move on to metrics to
calculate for alpha and beta diversity